the shock of the coronavirus
and it was a black swan event it was a
shock
but at the height of the great financial
crisis uh corporate debt non-financial
debt to gdp was
74 we entered 2020 with 78 percent
so we entered with corporate america's
balance sheet more levered up than it
had ever been coming out of this not
qe era because the fed absolutely had to
get reserves into the system there was
something very wrong with the plumbing
in september of 2019 and people who were
in the trenches knew it
knew it um but there was there was
something
that felt very orchestrated about
march 23rd you know
i you know and again i was not on the
inside but the coordination
and the the detailed
aspects of what the fed did tell me
that at least somebody at the new york
markets desk
came up with the game plan after you
know kind of the christmas eve bloodbath
that prompted
the powell pivot where he apologized on
january the 4th
2019 forever making these comments about
qe when he was a rookie in 2012 but
something tells me that the fed
knew the dangers and had started
studying it when
janet yellen made comments in front of
congress that she had some concerns
about
the collateral backing exchange traded
high yield funds
uh and it's a whole different whole
different dynamic
if you wouldn't mind getting into kind
of crossing that other
rubicon uh it's not just the s p 500
now we've delved into exchange traded
funds that are backed by
investment grade bonds high yield bonds
leverage loans for heaven's sake
so i this again is one of the things and
and i want to be clear when i say this
that i don't think that everything sits
you know passive isn't behind everything
but it is a huge
huge player in this and so particularly
when you talk about
fixed income markets i would actually
suggest that we are seeing
tremendous growth by you know in the the
share gain
for passive bond indices is actually
even more rapid than the share gain that
occurred for equities and part of that
is a function of the market position
and distribution channels of players
like blackrock and vanguard
who are able to negotiate preferential
access
to any number of savings programs etc
and if you're a registered investment
advisor
you know vanguard and blackrock can
afford to take you out golfing while the
vast majority of people no longer really
can right and so there's
again not just cast aspersions on the
rias because that's not what they're
actually doing they believe the research
that says these are the best products
but part of the challenge that is
created when you have these passive
vehicles that have this really simple
algorithm says if you give me cash then
buy
and the construction of the indices
particularly within the fixed income
space is such that they are
market value weighted which means that a
company
gets greater representation or a debt
security gets greater representation
in the index the larger the issue is so
the more debt that is outstanding
and the second is the higher the price
is right and so perversely we all know
that fixed income
instruments will only return a fixed
amount over their lives
but paradoxically the construction of
these fixed income indices are such that
if a bond is trading at 150
it is 50 more attractive than a bond
that's trading at par
right 100. now that's insane we know
that's insane but that's how these
indices are constructed
right and it also drives an underlying
dynamic where
if you are a issuer if you're a
corporation that's issuing debt
all you care about is that you get
vanguard or blackrock or one of the
index providers to buy your debt because
they're not going to do any analysis on
the covenants they're not going to do
any analysis
on your ability to repay etc they're
going to assume
everybody else has done that work
and as a result if the wall of money is
going into people who assume that
everyone else has done the work
you end up with debts that are priced as
if
they're flawless right and they're
distinctly flawed many of these
securities that occupy these indices
no longer have the covenants associated
with them they're what referred to as
cub light or no covenant
in many situations those aren't debt
securities
debt securities actually give you a
preferential right to direct management
once the asset value has fallen below a
certain level if you have no covenants
to enforce that
you've just bought really terrible
equity but that's how these
these funds and these indices are
constructed
yeah if um i i actually just did a deep
dive
into recovery rates and because we've
got
quietly in the background we have
bankruptcies running at the highest
since 2009.
uh and recovery is running well below
them
right i mean that's right recoveries
were 79 cents on the dollar
uh and that was as bad as they got on
leveraged loans right now they're 47
cents
and high yield bond recoveries are 15
on the dollar i mean the lowest we got
last time i think was 22 cents
i mean these are i i can't even wrap my
head around this stuff
stop and think about this we literally
just had saber energy which was a high
yield issuer in the energy space
their bonds went no recovery goldman
sachs had to take the bonds because
there was no bid for the assets
yes right i mean i i don't think i've
ever seen that happen for a publicly
traded security before but that's
exactly what you would expect to happen
when the only buyer is an index provider
that assumes that whatever price it was
able to come out at is the right price
which
sets up an incentive structure for me as
a participant in the underwriting
to say okay well i can dump it off to
vanguard as long as i know that it's
going to go into this index
the corporation gains extraordinary
leverage the management team gains
extraordinary leverage because they're
able to construct this with no covenants
etc
right and as a result we're getting
exactly what you would expect
and an incredible mispricing of the
worst quality debt we've ever seen
i mean when we came into when we came
into 2020
morgan stanley did just the back of the
envelope that said
42 of the investment grade universe on
planet earth
should have been rated junk and was not
and that's why i say that it feels like
there was such a script behind
what the fed was doing because they
backstopped grandfathered in and
backstopped anything
that was downgraded as a fallen angel
from investment grade to high yield
after march the 22nd and now we've had
record fallen angels
and we just i feel like we are still in
the process
of whistling past the graveyard and
i mean my final question to you which
i'm not going to get to yet
is has has to do with what can break
this dynamic
but first i want to ask you a little bit
more of a philosophical
question uh because there has been
something of an
outgrowth of a combination of
indexing and don't fight the fed and
you know not to be there's no hyperbole
here but but have we returned to a sort
of
robber robber baron era in the united
states where in
the way markets are structured feeds
into
the growth of some of the largest
companies
along with this idea of don't fight the
fed you just need to be long
well so i i um
yes i think that we are in a new robber
baron era and i do think that the
structure of the markets
particularly the dynamics of passive
investing
facilitates the accumulation of capital
at the highest levels
right and so just very quickly i
referred to the financial
to the fixed income bond uh index
construction where
market value determines how much money
goes into a
into an issue or into a company we have
the same thing as it relates to equities
right so they are float weighted or
market cap weighted
in terms of their construction that
means that if they go up in price
the next dollar that comes in puts more
money in
on a relative basis right and so it
creates momentum and that's exactly what
we've seen
has been the dominance of momentum
strategies
over value strategies which would
require
people to make a discretionary choice of
is this a good value
or is it a bad value right and so what
we've done is we've taken money away
from those making those discretionary
choices given it to those
who only make momentum choices and we've
created a continued
inflow of capital because of the
dominance of passive vehicles and things
like
401ks so while we talk about passive
share
being somewhere in the neighborhood of
50 of managed assets
about 40 percent of u.s equity assets
overall about 25
of us fixed income assets that's a very
poor characterization of the actual
structure of the market
because the younger generations those
who are actively saving as compared to
those who are withdrawing their capital
they're over 90 passive right so all the
money that's coming in
more than a hundred percent of the flows
into the market
is coming into passive vehicles that
have these momentum weights
and what of course that means is is that
each incremental dollar more of it goes
to an apple
or to a google or to a microsoft than it
does
to other securities and in
our analysis at least that creates a
disparity impact that that creates a
reinforcing loop
on that type of momentum behavior and
the only way that ends
is when money starts to come out of
those types of strategies
um well we'll again
hold that thought for just another uh
but is there a difference between
kind of blindly having
most of your of your proceeds most of
what you're saving
on your behalf flowing into a 401k and
actively building a diversified
portfolio of etf so you've got each
i mean you've got etfs everywhere i
think they're more etfs now than there
are mutual funds
uh but but are
are there certain venues are there
certain uh portfolios where
you can build out kind of a traditional
think about the efficient frontier
a traditional well-diversified portfolio
of etfs
um so one of the interesting things is
while there's been a massive
proliferation of etfs
um there's i personally track somewhere
in the neighborhood of 1500 etfs right
so i know there's more than that but
that's
the cutoff basically of that 1500 which
are the largest etfs in the u.s markets
only 50 are gaining assets
right so the etf space in aggregate
is really dominated by a few small
players like
voo the vanguard etf vbr
which is a another you know vanguard
type products blackrock type products
state steep street type products some
invesco products
just completely dominate the growth
that's occurring in the industry
those account for more than a hundred
percent of the flows that are going into
the etf space and so the kind of
you know interesting thematic sort of
thing like you know
a robot etf or a green energy etf those
will occasionally capture people's
attention
but they don't really fit into the very
simple asset allocation models that many
registered investment advisors and
financial advisors are choosing for
their clients
they kind of treat it as like well
that's play money right you can put a
little bit
into those but at your core should be
the vanguard total market index a
vanguard bond index
you know a uh vanguard international
exposure and a vanguard
maybe a small cap or a vanguard you know
uh
tax advantaged uh bond type fund right
whether that's tips or anything else
right
super simple portfolios that's what
everybody is looking for
they want simplicity and the etfs play
into that
but only in a very narrow space
so um how how does the fed and qe
play into how and i'm speaking
i'm speaking more about the actual level
of
purchases made on a on a monthly basis
all of that money
pouring into the financial system how
does that make its way through
to bolstering liquidity
helping put a floor underneath markets
well i think that's one of the things
that's so fascinating is is this idea of
a fed put or this idea that the fed will
step in to
bail out investors and is there to
protect investors
that's really only a narrative that
occurs amongst discretionary managers
right
i mean no one who is 25 years old whose
participation in their the stock market
is tied to their 401k at work where
their employer has a three percent match
and you know they're automatically
routed into let's say they're 25 years
old so they'll turn
65 you know sometime in 2070 give her
uh yeah 20 20 75
they're gonna be in a target date fund
that is tied to
that maturity right that end of their
working
you know life nowhere in that strategy
does it say hey do you think the fed is
going to increase interest rates or
lower interest rates
at the next meeting right that
participation isn't involved in any way
shape or form nor is it incorporated
into the behavior of these target date
funds that now
represent the vast majority of the money
that is going into these types of
products
where the discretion occurs is on the
part of the active manager
who says i think the fed is going to
step in and therefore there's very
little risk therefore i don't need to
hold cash or i might even lever my
portfolio
to gain increased exposure to try to
keep up with the benchmarks right
that that i think is where that dialogue
of don't fight the fed etcetera exists
and we see this and the risk on risk-off
behavior
which is often a function of the active
discretionary managers
changing their direction or their
loadings and so that's what we really
saw
in the spring of 2020 there was no
change until the layoffs began
in march there was no change to
contributions in 401ks there was
nothing nothing changed right
and yet suddenly the active managers got
cold feet and they said oh my gosh this
is really really terrible we need to
sell
and so they tried to raise cash and
discovered that
they're lowering prices in order to
facilitate that
didn't attract additional buyers right
that same
25 year old doesn't get an alert from
their 401k that says hey prices are down
five percent versus yesterday
would you like to buy more right it just
doesn't happen
and as a result when they went to try to
sell
on that risk off event there were no
more buyers prices collapsed
now in terms of the fed behavior and
kind of this 23rd date
i think there's a couple of different
components that go into that
one is absolutely the fed stepped in
with some very
targeted actions for example supporting
bond funds through blackrock
right hiring blackrock to allocate
capital
is kind of the ultimate example to me of
you know giving the fox control of
feeding the hens
right the second thing though that
happened and this is one of those
weird market structure things that
people tend not to be aware of and again
i mentioned
uh the work of my friend vincent the
23rd
is roughly the date at which a target
date fund would have to look at their
portfolio and say okay we are supposed
to have a balance between
equities and bonds the bonds have risen
the equities have fallen so much so what
am i going to do
i'm going to sell bonds and i'm going to
buy equities
right that's what they have to do
contractually in their in their
target date fund structure well there's
a ready buyer for bonds because the fed
just announced that they're going to
increase the quantity of bonds that
they're going to buy
right so selling those bonds is easy
and going out and buying the equities
starts to drive the price of the
equities higher and immediately
everyone says oh guess what it was
because of fed qe that stock prices went
up that's
i think there's some truth to that but i
actually think that it has much more to
do with the systematic dynamics and
those dynamics have governed the last
four events march 23
2018 which was the bottom associated
with vomageddon
december 24th on 2018 it would have been
the 23rd
if that hadn't been a sunday so the 24th
is is the next day that's available to
you
then again we had it occur in september
23rd of 2000
uh it was 2019
that it was september 23rd and then we
had march 23rd again in 2020. these are
after option expires these are at the
point that the target date funds have to
start the rebalancing
is the fed aware of this i mean i've had
conversations with them i think they're
starting to be aware of it and so they
may there may be some coordination of
okay now would be a really good time
because it allows us to pretend that
we're actually doing this
but i'm a little skeptical that the fed
is actually fully aware of this
so what what is the magnitude of
versus let's say the 70 trillion that i
brought up before with rias that are
88 flowing into these etfs what is the
magnitude of target date funds kind of
just a broad versus this 70 trillion
dollar
kind of monster out there well so
it's quite small relative to that 70
trillion monster but remember that that
70 trillion monster incorporates all
global assets right so when you talk
about the size of these products
particularly for younger generations in
equities they become pretty meaningful
so
total market cap in the united states is
around three trillion
on any given day you're going to see
kind of
you know tens to hundreds of billions of
dollars worth trade
but remember that the difference on that
is quite small
right so if apple trades two billion
dollars worth of shares in a day but the
price only moves by a penny
that tells you that you had a pretty
tight balance between the buyers and the
sellers
if the price goes up a dollar or down a
dollar right
then that actually is telling you that
there was an imbalance in one direction
or another right
and so when the the target date funds
are stepping in as they did on march
23rd
of 2020 and buying because of an
underweight of like 10 percent
you're potentially talking somewhere in
the neighborhood of a hundred to two
hundred billion dollars worth of equity
buying that has to occur
that's giant yeah on any on any
given trading day absolutely yes so you
know it was interesting that right
before
his death that vogel said that passive
had become too big and
he was starting to make some rumblings
almost as if he'd been
talking on the phone with you uh about
passing this 50 line in the sand
uh and what the implications would be
if passive was really no longer passive
anymore because it was so
big yeah so i i think bogel had a
different
had a difficult place in history because
unquestionably his products
are adopted and used by millions of
americans
and have created a tremendous amount of
wealth
but his relationship with his the firm
he founded vanguard actually became
quite strained
in the late 1990s as vanguard began to
capitalize
on its market position and introduce
products
that made him nervous right so things
like etfs things like
active rebalancing he was generally
opposed to that and as you mentioned
as of kind of may 2017 he gave a speech
in which he said
you know if everyone were to go passive
it would be complete disaster markets
would fail
right most people tend to think that's
way off into the future
and the reason that they think that is
because they assume that markets are
truly liquid transparent relatively
frictionless etc
the data increasingly just doesn't
support that right the the the
participation in in
a strategy can very rapidly crowd a
market even one as large
as the s p 500 or the u.s equity markets
so uh you're you're ending this
perfectly
and demographically
is one aspect fundamentally is
another i mean from my perch following
the macro economy we're seeing permanent
joblessness rise
we're seeing joblessness climb up the
income ladder into white collar
uh we're also seeing what looks to be uh
not necessarily a second wave of the
virus but a full-blown second wave of
of layoffs and bankruptcies which had
tamped down in
august and september looked to be
picking back up
in october and i think if a lot of
companies feel that
the last few months of 2020 aren't going
to be this massive rebound that had been
factored in and priced in so
where do demographics play into passive
investing
and will fundamentals ever matter
because again what you're describing and
listening to i don't listen to it
i keep it on mute but when when
bloomberg's on in the background
there is a lot of talk about the idea of
qe infinity
in fact fed policy makers are saying
that qe's going to be a permanent
fixture
going forward and i think that that has
the potential to provide reassurance to
people
that status quo as it is today with
markets just
generally speaking having hiccups along
the way but but
rising steadily is what what could upset
that dynamic
well i mean there's a variety of things
that can upset the dynamic demographics
of course is one of them because we have
a large accumulated stockpile of assets
associated with the boomers and those
older than the boomers that
need to be liquidated right so when we
talk about iras or 401ks combined
they're about 17.5 trillion dollars in
assets
as they are increasingly managed by
things like target date funds or robo
advisor type frameworks it says you
should have x amount
in the s p 500 x amount in small cap x
amount
in international stocks etc as that
becomes more and more a function of
pre-programmed ages right and people are
looking for these very simplistic rather
than idiosyncratically composed
portfolios for all their flaws
at least people were doing somewhat
different things right
but when you have this sort of
demographic dynamic associated with the
baby boomers that ultimately need to
sell those assets
in order to fund their retirements to
fund their consumption
the real risk that you have is the
increase in fragility that's created
by these super simplistic algorithms
that simply say if you give me cash then
buy
and likewise if you ask for cash then
sell
well what price should i sell whatever
price i can get
right and that suggests to me that what
we're
likely to see is this type of behavior
where equities continue to become more
volatile fixed income
continues to become more volatile as the
process the price discovery is
increasingly impaired by these actors
because you're you're saying sell at
whatever price there is out there so put
in a market sell
well and and the perverse dynamic is so
the boston fed a
friend of mine at the boston fed an
individual who i respect a lot put out a
piece recently talking about passive
investing and does it represent
systematic risk right and
one of the things that they highlight
about things like etfs is that
potentially they reduce liquidity
demands because instead of being sold
for cash
they could theoretically be returned in
kind right so instead of you
having to sell your hyg and receiving
cash for it at a distressed price
well they could just give you the
underlying bonds right and i look at
that and i go that's
the most insane thing i've ever heard
right like what is the average american
going to do with a low-grade bond that
was suddenly deposited into their
account
when they asked for cash they're going
to sell it without any form of
professional trader
who's trying to find the best execution
of price they're just going to dump it
into the market this is
this is a complete disaster if that's
what you think is providing liquidity
and they have to like they know this
they have to know that's the case
but there's an extraordinary amount of
effort that is being put out
by organizations that people think
are working in their interest right
vanguard has a great story
about how they're out there for the
small investor etc and the
crazy part is i think they actually
believe it it's very cult-like behavior
there
but at the end of the day that's not a
solution and we saw this
you know many vanguard bond etf products
i would highlight something like bnd
for example that went to a that went to
a
seven percent discount to its nav in the
events of march
2020 right now that's 70 treasuries
so what that's telling you is is that
the corporate bond component of it which
is all investment grade
had to be trading at a 21 discount
right like that's not a liquid product
under those conditions and that's why
i would argue that the fed stepped in so
aggressively
to try to mitigate those risks on a
short-term basis
but exactly as you've said they've
separated us from the fundamentals which
continue to deteriorate many of those
situations well
there was a time in the days that
proceeded that the long bond itself was
not trading in asia and
trading in the middle of the night so i
mean
yeah there were lots of challenges
associated with that it wasn't this
is not what it used to be no it is
definitely and i think it's important
for people to remember
that liquidity doesn't always mean what
we think it means so when the fed
adds liquidity it doesn't mean that
they're actually out there facilitating
the transaction of the securities that
you happen to own
what they're actually saying when they
provide liquidity is is that they are
allowing people who
want to trade to borrow and post
collateral so that they can execute
right and by the same token we're not
seeing commercial and industrial loans
go up you know
the revolvers were initially drawn down
and now the the reserves are just
banks are piling into more and more and
more treasuries every day they're not
they're not making new loans
well and and we see not just that we
also see you know that tends to come
through as various forms of
misinformation
right so when a cni loan is taken down
or when a more importantly a line of
credit right
a revolver is taken down that money
flows into a money market mutual fund
and that then gets reported to the
public as oh look cash balances have
exploded
right and there's tons of tons of cash
on the sidelines
well there's a huge difference between
cash that was raised by individuals in
their brokerage accounts
and cash that was created because lines
of credit
or revolvers have been drawn down in
advance of the event those can't be used
to buy stocks
right and those ultimately have to be
repaid there's a subsequent withdrawal
of that liquidity
that is approaching and when that occurs
i would expect to see further stress in
the credit markets
yeah and you've already heard banks say
that they're already taking losses on
some of the retailers who
drew down those lines and are no longer
with us
[Music]